vice president kamala harris plans to
visit the southern border tomorrow after
hearing heavy criticism from republicans
harris is leading the biden
administration's response to the rise in
migrants seeking to enter the u.s
but so far she has not been to the
border to see the current situation
firsthand
nancy cordes is at the white house nancy
what can we expect from the vice
president's trip
well dreka we know that she is going to
be going to el paso tomorrow that she'll
be accompanied by
the secretary of homeland security
alejandro mayorkas but we don't know
much yet
about what she's going to be doing there
the white house
has not shared those details yet because
this trip is just coming together
republicans as you mentioned have been
hammering the vice president for not
going to the border
sooner she did make a trip to guatemala
and mexico
earlier this month and said there that
she's focused on addressing
the root causes of migration rather than
making quote
grand gestures like a photo op at the
border
this announcement about her trip comes
just days before former president trump
is set to visit the texas border next
week
the white house insisted to us that the
timing is unrelated and that this was
just
the right time for her to go this all
comes as the biden administration is
forcing out the current border patrol
chief who was appointed by
former president trump his name is
rodney scott he was at the helm of the
agency for less than two years he was a
vocal supporter
of mr trump's immigration policies
including the border wall
the biden administration has already
nominated its own pick to head the
border patrol he is tucson police chief
chris magnus
the deputy chief of the border patrol
will run the agency
in the meantime and nancy we're also
waiting on a long delayed infrastructure
deal where does that stand right now
progress we're told that a meeting
between the white house and senators
went very well yesterday that they made
a lot of progress in negotiating
some kind of compromise between this
bipartisan plan that has
been put forth by about 10 senators and
the white house plan one gop senator
said
that they are quote very close so close
in fact that the president has now
invited the senators
to come meet with him here at the white
house to hammer out the final details
today all right very close in progress
two words you don't always hear there
uh nancy thank you